ما وصول النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى الرياض انتشرت صوره ووثائق
تخص صديقته جورجينا فما القصه
ضجه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بالحديث عن
انتقال النجم العالمي وعائلته الى
السعوديه وانشغلت السعوديين بصديقه
رونالدو الفاتنه ونشر مغردون عبر موقع
تويتر صورا معدله بالفوتوشوب لهويه اقامه
جورجينا عند انتقاليها للعيش في الرياض
[موسيقى]
كما نشر اخرون الصور لها معدله بالفوتوشوب
وهي ترتدي قميص نادي النصر الى ذلك تطرق
اخرون الى اي مدارس يلتحق ابناء رونالدو
فيما ذهب اخرون الى اقتراح اماكن ومطاعم
للعائله الشهيره في حين تداول نشطاء انباء
عن مكان اقامه النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو في الرياض مشيرين الى انه تم
تجهيزه قصر له ولعائلته بمنطقه المحمديه
في العاصمه السعوديه
يذكر ان نادي النصر السعودي اعلن يوم
السبت تعاقده مع الاسطوره البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو رسميا حتى صيف عام 2025
[موسيقى]